[Applause]
the stage set for a party at Donald
Trump's Florida mansion but by the end
of the night there was little for him to
celebrate
a red tsunami had been hoped for a red
wave expected even in the end it was
barely a trickle well thank you very
much everybody it has been a very
exciting night we have uh some races
that are hot and heavy and we're all
watching them here
but try as he will to frame this as a
victory it was anything but
up and down the ballot and across this
country trump-backed candidates lost or
losing in key races
to Democrats who say theirs is a victory
over division tonight we must recommit
ourselves to the cause of our country
I'm here to make a difference I never
expected that we were going to turn
these red counties blue but we did what
we needed to do
John fetterman won a crucial Senate race
in Pennsylvania over TV personality
member Oz who Trump recruited and
rallied for Democrats might still lose
the house and even the Senate but this
crucially was not the shellacking that
had been trailed even Trump's allies had
to admit that of course candidates
matter candidates matter in every race
some of the Trump back candidates
weren't as good or didn't perform as
well as would have liked by any
standards this this wasn't a victory for
the trump-backed Republican party so do
you think Republicans stand by Donald
Trump I get it many in the media many of
the establishment Republicans are trying
to tap dance on President Trump and try
to say this is some sort of rebuke
against him but like I said before no
such thing as ugly wins
Trump is holed up in his marriage
Marlton Racing for Hurricane Nicole
arriving on these Shores but there are
other tempestuous events on the horizon
if anything they've served to highlight
yet again that he's far from being a
guaranteed winner on the national stage
and now the Republican Party must decide
whether they continue to align
themselves with him
a potential alternative is poised close
by Florida Governor Ron DeSantis won by
a landslide he is a different vessel for
trumpism we will never ever surrender to
the woke mob Florida is where woe goes
to die
he doesn't have much support in Florida
but the midterms have also handed
President Biden an unexpected boost with
votes still being counted and control of
Congress unclear his next two years
could still be fraught with legislative
roadblocks but this was not the
political Armageddon he was staring down
Martha Kellner Sky News Florida